welcome to this video yeah this is just
a very short video to show um the videos
in a German language that I am now
producing for the ICC it's um
unfortunately not possible to post links
in YouTube
I mean in the text video description so
I'm just making a short video to show
um how it is found and um
it's of course just for ICC members but
you can get an idea
um the icc's address is chessclub.com
so go here
and um
here you can select watch videos
and then it shows them
English videos that the ICC has
basically in English you get a video
update every day
with various grandmas who saw
International Masters like John Watson
posting videos and the new thing is you
can also select the
German language and then you'll get um
get to my stuff because the German video
um
part of the site is basically just my
videos
um I did four videos
um about
um Gap basically learning chess I mean
the chess rules and very very basic
things like mating with with a single
queen and with a rook and um
the basic principles of opening played
like developing piecings pieces and so
on this is for videos that um probably
are not useful to you but may be useful
to people that want to want to learn
chess these are also completely free so
for for example if you select one of
those those videos
it will will start here and um
this is free for for everyone to see
here I'm I think explaining the the
chess um
the opening rules how to develop stuff
um the probably more interesting videos
for
the YouTube audience also would be the
this new series
um
the opening compass
um which is um an opening show which is
um done every two weeks
the first term has been just released a
couple of days ago on Christmas
Christmas day even or Christmas Eve and
um this will be a multi-part show
um
lasting for a couple of months to show a
complete Black repertoire
um based on relatively simple lines that
can be played on general principles
these videos are only um for ICC members
so
um and of course they're in German so uh
for the English speaking audience they
are not that interesting probably so um
only for members the only thing you can
do if you if you are German and you are
basically able to understand the video
you can
play uh him
five minutes of it the first part is
um 30 minutes and you can see the first
five minutes where basically
um explain the
the basic idea of the series
um yeah if you're a member of ICC
this is the way you can get to the
videos go to the ICC webpage
and then go to videos and German or
Deutsch or maybe um just single link
here
also should um should work yeah it does
work but I cannot paste it into YouTube
so
it's nothing you can just click on in
the description
um yeah and if you think about joining
the ICC it has got um I think lots of
benefits and uh if you if you're
interested you can just join for a month
and have a look I think it's just a
couple of euros
and um if you don't like it well then
just do one month and um
look at somewhere else but I'm I'm
playing on the ICC for 15 years now and
it's the only server that I regularly
play on really
yeah thanks for watching just a quick
pointer to those German videos and enjoy
the last days of um 2012. bye